[SIDE CONVERSATION]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
CARY CLARK: Hi.
My name is Cary Clark, and I'm
a member of the Skia team.
Skia provides the graphics
for Android, the Android
framework, and for Chrome.
Skia draws the rectangles, the
bitmaps, the text, and paths.
That's what I'm going
to talk about today,
paths and path ops.
I started working at Apple a
long time ago, and at that
time, the Apple II really
started my love of graphics.
The Apple II had a high
resolution bitmap with a 280
by 192 screen--
it had a pair of
them, actually.
And with that, the world
was my oyster.
I could draw anything I wanted,
and it was just amazing.
Unfortunately, the Apple II
didn't really have any
built-in graphics routines
at that time.
Sometime later, when I was
introduced to the Lisa and the
Macintosh computers, I learned
about QuickDraw, and QuickDraw
is the software on a Macintosh,
on the original
Macintosh, that drew
to the screen.
QuickDraw had arcs, and that was
my first introduction into
a computer that had a curved
primitive, a circular arc.
A little while later, the
Macintosh had the LaserWriter,
which was a PostScript
printer.
PostScript had a whole new class
of curves called cubic
beziers, which were pretty
exotic, but they looked great,
especially when they
were scaled up.
And it was pretty mind-blowing
how well PostScript could take
a document and rotate it
or skew it or scale it.
In 1988, TrueType, and a little
before that, QuickDraw
GX came out.
I was fortunate enough to
work on QuickDraw GX.
And at that time, I decided to
add quadratics to QuickDraw
instead of cubics or arcs.
The quadratic is a little bit
simpler than a cube-- it has
one less control point, but
it has a lot of the same
properties, and I was happy
that TrueType also chose
quadratics and allowed me to
have some validation that my
choice was a good one.
Skia has all of these types.
It has arcs, it has cubics,
quadratics, and now it has
conics, which are sections
of a cone, which include
quadratics.
And a path op is a way to take
all of these curves and
operate on them with
set operations.
When QuickDraw was introduced
back in the '80s, it had a way
of describing an area of the
screen that was called a
region, and it was just a
collection of rectangles, but
it was the basis for the
Macintosh windows and the
windowing system.
A little while later with
PostScript and QuickDraw GX
and so forth, paths were
introduced, and paths, like
regions, describe an
area of the screen.
But that area can include
circles and triangles, and
it's a control point
based area.
So instead of a set of
rectangles, it's something
that can have arbitrary curves
and arbitrary lines.
QuickDraw used its
rectangle-based path, its
region, to build a
windowing system.
And the windowing system allowed
QuickDraw to draw to
just the part of the window
that was visible.
The way it did this is it had
operations called region ops
that could do things like
intersect a pair of regions or
take the difference of
one from the other.
This was a very powerful concept
that Bill Atkinson,
the author of QuickDraw,
invented.
I liked it so much that I wanted
to do the same thing
for QuickDraw GX.
But instead of just making it
work for rectangles, I wanted
it to work for any arbitrary
geometry and be able to rotate
or skew a path and
operate on it.
With ordinary paths-- say,
a pair of ovals--
it's very difficult to translate
those ovals from one
graphic system to another.
For instance, Skia can describe
a path with a pair of
ovals, but to do a hardware
acceleration and translate
those ovals to something like
OpenGL, it's difficult,
because OpenGL doesn't have a
primitive that will describe
those curves.
Worse, if each oval individually
is sent to
OpenGL, the pair of curves may
not blend together well.
If either one has transparency,
then you'll see
the transparent addition of the
two rather than just the
area that the two describe.
That's why OpenGL systems often
create stencil buffers
that have the bitmap that
describes, in this case, a
pair of ovals and uploads that
rather than uploading the
geometry of those
pair of ovals.
The Blink portion of Chrome that
reads into the HTML web
page can create some very
complicated geometries.
CSS allows defining different
gradients for different parts
of a rounded rectangle,
for instance.
So the clip might look
something like this
illustration.
That clip is only the portion
of the gray--
is the only portion that's
actually drawn.
But the clip contains all the
other shapes as well.
It's difficult to do an
acceleration of just the
portion that's being drawn when
all the other geometries
are present in the clip stack.
Blink also allows drawing the
difference of a shape.
So when going from Skia to PDF,
for instance, we have to
draw the PDF data into an
off-screen bitmap and render
that instead of being able to
calculate the geometry that
would result from subtracting
a rectangle
from another rectangle.
Shape ops tries to address
this need.
Here, this simplify operation
takes a pair of blue
rectangles and will compute
the area that would result
from drawing both of them.
This is the simplest path op.
Path ops also have binary
operations to compare paths.
So in this case, we're computing
the intersection of
a pair of rectangles from
two separate rectangles.
The union operator looks a lot
like the simplify operator.
It uses two paths, each with a
single contour, instead of one
path with two contours.
A contour is a closed portion
of a path, so it's a
continuous closed loop.
There's a pair of difference
operators.
This difference operator
subtracts the dark green
rectangle from the blue one.
There's a reverse difference
that would subtract the blue
rectangle from the
dark green one.
For completeness, there's also
exclusive or, although this
one isn't used very much.
And finally, there's complement,
which describes
all of the area that's
outside of a path.
As it turns out, there's
no special function for
complement because Skia's paths
have a way of describing
whether it's the fill
or the inverse fill.
So the complement is just
toggling those two attributes.
There's no reason to implement
all of these path ops as
separate functions since
they're really
all the same thing.
In this illustration, we have
the paths A and B and their
complements running down the
column on the left and
different path operations
running in the
row across the top.
So you can see that the
intersection of A and B is the
same as the difference of A
complement B, or the exclusive
or of A and B is the same as the
union of A minus B and B
minus A is also the difference
between the
intersection and the union.
So what's all this good for?
Back when fonts were originally
ported to
computers, a lot of times the
complex characters were
created by drawing individual
characters on top of each
other, like a slash on top of
the letter O. If you drew the
outline of those characters,
you'd get an undesirable
result as shown here because you
would see both outlines at
the same time where you'd really
like to see only the
portion described by the area
of the two characters.
So the question is how do we
get from there to here?
When I first wrote this in the
'80s, my approach was very
similar to the way I drew
these characters.
I would start by finding
the maxima and
minima of the curves.
Once they were split, I would
then find all the vertical
occurrences where either a new
curve started, a new curve
stopped, or a pair of
intersections occurred.
Given all those vertical events,
I would sort them and
then walk across them
horizontally and find every
place where one of the
curves intersected
that horizontal line.
Then I would have to
sort those as well.
Finally, if a pair of curves or
a line and a curve had the
same y value for some given x
value, I had to sort those to
know which one would
contribute to
the final path first.
All of the sorting is required
because of something called
the winding number rule.
And the winding number rule says
that the direction of the
path describes whether it
contributes or subtracts from
the output.
So in this case, the down arrows
contribute a plus 1 to
the answer and the up
arrows contribute a
minus 1 to the answer.
If I sum those numbers as I
move across from left to
right, every time that a 0
changes to a 1 or a 1 changes
to a 0, that's a line
that I keep.
If it changes from one positive
number to another,
those are lines I discard.
That will give me the desired
output that I want.
This time around, it occurred
to me that all that sorting
was a lot of work and took a
lot of time, and there was
probably a simpler approach.
In fact, there are really only
eight intersection points
between these pairs of curves
and lines that I
actually care about.
All the other sorting
information is superfluous to
the real answer.
If I look at any one of those
intersections, instead of
thinking about how the y-number
is affected as I
traverse across the entire shape
from left to right, I
can think about what the winding
number contribution is
at that intersection point as
I move around in a circle.
If I know what the intersection
is as each curve
contributes to the answer, once
again, when 0 moves to 1
or 1 moves to 0, those
are lines I keep.
But when it goes from one
positive number to the next,
those are lines I discard.
The great benefit of this is
once I have one answer, that
answer propagates around the
rest of the curve so I don't
need to keep computing the
inside or outsideness of the
shape, and I can keep all of
the information all the way
around to the point I run into
another intersection.
But before I can get there, I
have to be able to find the
intersections.
So let's take a look at one
of the curve types.
This is a quadratic bezier
defined by a couple of control
points on the ends and one
control point in the middle.
The quadratic bezier is parallel
to the end points.
The tangents of the quadratic
bezier from the first to the
second point define how
the curve groups.
A pair of quadratic beziers
are portions of a pair of
parabolas, so they can
intersect in as
many as four points.
So that's a clue as to what the
answer's going to be to
find the intersection of
a pair of quadratics.
I'll need to be able to find
at least four solutions.
So if there is a solution, it's
going to have to be able
to find four roots.
Back in the original
illustration, I mentioned that
I have to divide the curves
into a pair--
I had to divide the curves at a
maxima and a minima before I
could proceed.
This is because everything
was sorted in y.
The first time I did this, I
thought that also meant that
it simplified the solution
for the intersection
of a pair of curves.
I thought if there are four
intersections for a pair of
parabolas, surely there are
only two intersections if
they're subdivided so they
only increase in y.
I was wrong.
There are three intersections
for monotonically increasing
curves, and this was quite
embarrassing when I figured it
out for the first time
back in the '80s.
So this time around, I decided
to be much more careful about
the mathematics and the geometry
so I wouldn't fall
into the same sort
of mistake again.
So let's take a look at
intersecting a pair of curves.
For these curves, I want to find
the intersection and I
want to do so by creating the
mathematics that will solve
the answer directly.
Another approach would be to
subdivide the curves, but
we'll talk about that
in just a moment.
If I look at what the solution
is without looking at how I'm
going to get there, I can
imagine that there's a value
called t which varies
from 0 to 1 as I
traverse across the curve.
When t is equal to 0,
it's going to be at
the C0 and C0 prime.
When t is at 1, it's
going to be at C2.
And anywhere in between, it's
going to describe a point
along the curve.
So for these sample pieces of
data, the t is a 1.25 for one
curve and 0.623 for the other.
And when I plug the t into some
equation, I'll get the
same intersection point
for both curves.
In Skia, by the way, the y
point's down instead of up, so
things may look a little upside
down from the math
you're used to.
So let's get back to solving
curves by subdividing.
This solution is the one that I
used originally in the '80s,
and it's very popular today as
well, and there's been a lot
of work to optimize this such as
the work by T. W. Sederberg
at BYU using convex hulls
to optimize subdivision.
I found this solution ultimately
unworkable because
it falls down when two curves
are very close to the same.
In this case, every time the
curves are subdivided, the
pair of curves are still
very close to the same.
And even though they don't
touch each other, it's
impossible to tell without
further subdivision.
So I found in this case that it
was a very long tail before
I would know whether or not
the solution was found.
So this is a solution I
tried and abandoned.
So going back to the math
approach, this is the
Bernstein equation for a
quadratic bezier, and it
simply describes the x and y
values for some value of t
from 0 to 1.
As I said before, if t is
0, the answer is C0.
If t is 1, the answer is C2.
And if the t is any
other value, it's
somewhere along the curve.
The simplified form of the
equation collects the values
together so that now I have a
simple quadratic which is very
easy to solve.
The implicit form of the
equation is a little more
complicated, but it describes an
entire parabola instead of
the quadratic section which is
a piece of that parabola.
Even though the math looks
daunting, it turns out there's
enough common terms that it only
takes about 28 multiplies
and 11 adds to get from
the simple form to
the implicit form.
Once I have both the implicit
and parametric forms of the
equation, I can plug
one into the other.
So I can take the second
equation, which describes how
x and y are in terms of t, and
I can plug that answer into
the third equation to get rid
of the t altogether and have
something I can solve for t.
Once I have the quartic
equation, now I can find the
solution that will give me
the intersection of one
curve with the other.
But this just gets me the t
values for the first curve.
I have to do the reverse and
plug the second equation into
the first in order to get the
complement, in order to get
the t values for the
prime equation.
Once I have the t values for
both equations, I can plug
them in and ensure that they
return the same x and y values
for each of the quadratics.
Since I have a quadratic
solution that's robust and
works well, you might think I
would also be able to use that
same solution for cubics.
After all, cubics are just
quadratics with one more
control point, so they can't be
that much more complicated.
Here's the Bernstein polynomial
for a cubic
equation, which looks a lot
like the quadratic one.
It just has one more
term, and this has
cubes instead of squares.
If I overlay a pair of cubics
on top of each other, I'll
find that they can have as many
as nine intersections,
and this ought to set off alarm
bells because it's going
to be very hard to find nine
roots for an equation.
If I plug the equation into
Mathematica, I get a rather
daunting-looking result.
And notice that this still has
everything in terms of x and
y, so this is not the
complete solution.
This is half of it--
I still have to plug all of the
x and y values from the
alternate equation into
this equation.
So things are looking sad
for solving cubics with
mathematics.
Sure enough, if I work all the
way through, I'll end up with
a ninth ordered equation
for which there
is no general solution.
And even though there's a lot
of advancements in root
finding and computers are much
faster than they were 25 years
ago, people haven't got a whole
lot smarter, so this
sort of equation is impossible
to solve
directly in a robust manner.
So let's take a look
at the cubic again.
This cubic intersects itself, so
not only do I need to find
how the cubic intersects another
cubic, but I need to
know its own intersection.
This gives me a clue as to
how I might solve the
intersection.
Rather than try to solve the
cubic directly, I can
approximate it with a series of
quadratics and then use my
quadratic intersection to find
the actual solution.
Once I get the intersection
values in t with quadratics, I
can take those same t values
and apply them back to the
cubic and then check to
see if they return the
same x and y value.
This turns out to be a pretty
robust solution
that works very well.
So here's a pair of cubics
that intersect each other
connected to a line.
For lines in cubics and lines
and the lines and the lines in
quadratics, I can solve
those directly.
I don't have to do
any special math.
So this line does not intersect
cubic one-- it just
misses touching it--
but the pair of cubics
intersect each other.
When I approximate one cubic
with a quadratic, the
quadratic approximation is very
close, which is fine.
It's just exactly what
I want it to be.
The cubic continues off to the
right, and as the cubic
continues, the quadratic
approximation drifts a little
bit further away,
but not too far.
But for the first cubic, its
endpoints are far off the
screen, and so the quadratic
approximation at this point is
the furthest it ever gets
from the cubic.
So even though the line does not
intersect the cubic, it's
also the case that the pair of
quadratics do not intersect
each other.
So using a straightforward
solution, I miss this
intersection altogether,
and my path ops
produce the wrong result.
To find the intersection of the
cubics, I have to rely on
the convex hull.
The convex hull is what happens
when you connect all
the control points of
the cubic together.
It describes a polygon around
which the cubic is guaranteed
to be contained by.
If I look at the very end of
the convex hull, these tiny
little line segments, then I can
find the intersections of
those lines with the opposing
cubic and use that to find the
intersections of the
pair of cubics.
Since I only have to do this
at the very ends of the
cubics, it's a trivial
computation, and it allows the
entire calculation
to be robust.
Now that I have the
intersections of cubics,
quadratics, and lines, then I
can get back to performing my
path operations.
As before, I'd like to find
all of the places where an
intersection travels, and I
would like compute all the
crossings in a circle.
And as I move counterclockwise
around all of those crossings,
I'd like to accumulate the
winding number to know which
edges to keep and which
edges to discard.
In this example, a triangle and
a pair of circles touch at
the same point, and there are
two lines and two quadratics
that all descend from that
point, and I need to sort them
as I move around
counterclockwise.
When I sort the pair of lines,
the answer is straightforward.
The direction of the line allows
me to know which line
is to the left of the other
using a simple cross product.
For the line in the quadratic, I
can't use that trick because
the initial tangent of
the quadratic is
the same as the line.
But I can use the fact that the
quadratic curls away from
the line to know whether it
curls to the right or the left
of the line.
For a pair of quadratics, the
answer is not so simple.
This particular pair of
quadratics have exactly the
same implicit equation--
that is, they're part of the
same parabola, and for that
matter, they're the exact same
part of that same parabola, so
they have the same
curved shape.
And if I take the derivative of
each curve, I won't get any
more information because the
derivative will be identical
for these two.
So even though it's clear by
looking at them that Q2 is to
the left of Q1, it's hard
to figure that out
mathematically.
My solution for now is to take
the shorter of the two
tangents and bisect that with
the shorter of the start end
points and sort those
intersections.
Empirically, this produces the
right result, although there
may be a better one.
All of this sorting falls
apart when the
numerics become small.
So here I have a line that
travels between two points off
screen, and here are the
approximations of that line as
represented by little circles.
This grid represents the
floating point resolution
that's available to me, so if
my numbers are in doubles,
then each grid line represents
the smallest possible value
that that double
can represent.
In other words, there's no way
to represent any value smaller
than the grid lines.
When I intersect a pair of
lines, I'm going to find at
best the number that is the
truncation of the actual
intersection.
In other words, because double
precision is finite,
everything's going
to round down.
Here's the second line that
intersects the original line.
And once again, the intersection
as the best
possible approximation rounds
down, and it's represented by
the red circle.
When I consider which of these
lines I would encounter first
when traveling from left to
right, I see visually that the
blue line is to the left
of the red line.
But when I walk across and look
at the answers that I
received from the intersection,
I hit the red
dot before I hit the blue dot.
So basically, the
math lied to me.
It gave me the wrong
intersection.
As it turns out, this would not
be important because this
little triangular sliver, even
though it would be incorrectly
computed, is so small
it wouldn't draw.
It would simply disappear.
But if I'm doing the same work
with a curve instead a pair of
lines, then all of a sudden the
area described between the
blue line and the red curve can
become very large, and my
error likewise becomes
very large.
And now my answer is
wrong for a large
portion of the path op.
This means that for a lot of
computation, I need just to
decide that the answer
is just unknowable.
It may be unsortable, it may
be tiny, or it may be
unorderable, but I can't
necessarily compute what the
answer is for an intersection.
To solve this in the general
case, I simply find another
intersection that I do know and
propagate that answer back
to the intersection
that I don't know.
If a pair of shapes exactly
overlap each other as in the
case of this pair of rectangles,
the path op is
pretty straightforward
to compute.
In this case, the dark green
rectangle is below the blue
one, and so I just want to
return the top of the blue one
as the answer.
A lot of the online references
that I researched suggest that
when points are difficult to
compute, that you could jiggle
the points in order to compute
the actual answer, but this is
a case where jiggling
is destructive.
If I move the lower rectangle's
shapes around a
little bit to avoid having
coincident points, then my
answer will have extra little
spikes on them.
All these spikes are so small
they may not draw.
They prevent me from having a
convex result, which might be
a special operation or a special
optimization when the
shape is accelerated.
Also, it prevents me from
knowing the actual balance of
the resulting shape, and it
makes the testing hard,
because I can't guarantee that
a tap on the shape won't
accidentally be inside one of
those little triangles.
So this is one reason why
jiggling, I think, is not a
robust solution to path ops.
While I can't do jiggling, I
also can't do precise math
because there's enough error
term in all these calculations
that I always have to worry
about what the error is.
So I spent a lot of time
thinking about the unit of
least precision, which
is the error term.
When I compare numbers between
0 and 1, I can describe
exactly what that error is, and
the error I chose is the
smallest amount that a floating
point value can
represent, a 32-bit float
can represent.
This computation can be done all
in float space or in the
[INAUDIBLE]
registers or the [INAUDIBLE]
registers on an ARM chip, and
it's a fairly fast computation
to make.
When the values are arbitrary,
as an ordinary x and y point
part of a Cartesian coordinate,
then the only
reasonable way to determine the
equality is to look at the
integer bit representation of
the floating point numbers.
This is expensive because it
requires taking the original
float values and moving them out
of the float registers and
into the integer ALU before the
comparison can be done,
and that will always stall
the float pipeline.
So whenever possible, I work in
t space between 0 and 1 and
avoid comparing x's and y's
as much as I possibly can.
I have a whole lot of epsilon
values that I currently use,
depending on the complexity
of the math.
I hope over time to simplify
and reduce the number of
epsilons required to perform
this calculation.
And a lot of these are seat of
the pants numbers, but they're
the best I know how to do.
There's a lot of unanswered
questions in path ops.
For instance, here's a shape
that has more than one
possible solution.
When I simplify it, it I might
end up with an L-shaped
corner, or I might end
up with a small
rectangle in the middle.
Both of these are equally valid
answers, and there's no
reason to prefer one over the
other, but one might be more
desirable for graphics
acceleration, for instance.
And currently, I don't have a
way for the algorithm or the
user to choose one
over the other.
Similarly, I don't have a way of
choosing winding direction.
So here are two shapes with
different winding.
The top one winds to the right
on the outer contour, and the
bottom one winds to the left.
While these draw equivalently
and are otherwise identical,
they might have different
results-- for instance, if you
dash the shapes, because the
dashing is going to start at a
different point, and it's
going to travel
in a different direction.
This is another area where I
don't have a way to choose one
over the other nor know what
the user's real intent was.
Finally, right now I
only compute areas.
So for instance, given this
rotated rectangle and a
rectangular clip, I return a
parallelogram, which is the
area of the intersection.
But there may be some reason
to return a pair of lines
instead because those lines
would be the part of the frame
that's visible inside
the clip.
This is another case where I
don't know what the user's
intent was, and I also don't
know if the lower answer is an
answer that's valuable.
To this point, I'm only coding
the answers that actually have
a practical use.
Once there's a need for this
sort of computation, it's an
easy thing to add, but I'll wait
until it shows up as an
optimization for Skia
before I add it.
Here's the current
source code.
Everything is public, open
source, and checked in, and
you can go get any of the path
ops code, the interfaces, or
the sources here.
And I'm going to spend a few
minutes talking about how I
debugged and wrote path ops
and show you a small demo.
And I'm going to do
my updates later.
When I generate path ops, I do
a lot of printfs, and the
printfs look a lot like this.
And while these numbers are
helpful, sometimes they're
very hard to visualize, so I
wrote a way to visualize them.
Oops-- how do I get
there from here?
There we go.
This is a web page that contains
a canvas, and the
canvas contains the printf
output that I showed earlier,
which is at the bottom
of the screen.
The top part of the screen shows
visualizing that output
and visualizing pieces
of that output.
So for instance, all of these
little circles show the
winding values that are computed
for this shape.
And if I look at a pair of these
shapes, a pair of these
tests, I can see at least one
place where I computed a
different answer on the
two different shapes.
That's where the bug was that
I had to trace down here.
This particular canvas allows me
to see a lot of information
about the path ops
that I compute.
For instance, I can see all of
the edges as they're first
computed, and then I can step
through each set of edges and
watch how they're processed.
Or I can see the edges as
they're output so that I know
at what point in the code
each edge is generated.
So here's the output that this
particular test generated, and
here's the output that the test
that failed generated.
So I can compare the two and
have a pretty good idea where
things went wrong.
Here's another example that
shows a pair of cubics, and it
also shows the quadratics that
were generated to approximate
those cubics.
So this is actually showing
both the cubics and the
quadratics at the same time,
but I can look at just the
quadratics, or I can look at
just the cubics and make sure
that my answers are accurate.
And as you can see here, there's
very little visible
difference between the quadratic
approximation and
the actual cubic curve.
This one is going to show
the actual data that a
web page passes me.
So this comes off of
eldorado.com, and it contains
a parallelogram containing a
rounded rect that is also a
parallelogram, and this
is actual CSS data
that describes a clip.
This particular data is
deceptive because even though
those lines look like they touch
each other, they don't.
They're actually very close but
not the same, and makes
the math hard to figure out.
And here are some other examples
of actual web pages
and the clips that they produce
that drive me crazy.
For any of these, I can show the
data that's generated, and
then I can also show
the printfs that
generated that data.
And by advancing through the
data visually and advancing
through the text, I can then go
back to my C code and set
break points and figure out
where things went wrong.
This has been a very helpful
tool for me.
So now I'd like to show
you a quick demo
of path ops in action.
So here we are running some of
the unit tests that I've
written for path ops.
At this point I have around 73
million tests, and we're
seeing a few of them here.
Each of these tests is drawing
the path ops and
computing the result.
It's also using Skia to create
a region with the original
shapes and the result.
Then I compare the bits drawn
by my path ops and the bits
drawn by the region and make
sure there's not any
conservable amount of error
between the two.
This is part of the Skia Unit
Test Suite, and this is run
every time Skia is built on
all platforms, including
Android, Chrome OS, Mac,
Windows, and Linux in 32-bit
and 64-bit.
So I've made sure that this
code is robust and works
across a lot of different
platforms.
So that's it for the
presentation.
I hope you enjoyed it.
Please write me if you
have any questions.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]